[Music]
remember that story that they told us
about in training
about george washington's first female
spy during the revolution
they called her agent 355
because they didn't want the world to
know her real name
but her legacy lives on
[Music]
we're the top agents from around the
world
american
british
german colombian chinese
but now we have a common enemy
they can start world war three
from simple reach of their keyboard so
we need to join forces
it's like half the cia's most wanted
always such a tough guy
i'm not an agent i'm a therapist they
thought it would give you my secrets do
you have secrets
we put ourselves in danger so that
others are not
i'll handle the guns
are you in therapy i should be
you're the best in the world of what you
do you have cameras in your jewelry
combs in your earrings you bump i grab
the target is on the move you're not
going in there alone we go together
i have a family i cannot do this anymore
the bad guys are out there right now
you go home
you bring them with you
are you under control are you no
black cars all black everything i've got
four more agents out on the street i
counted six but thanks for the tip
i like the new team we're the 355.
[Music]
[Music]
you